in this video I want to talk about an
initiator tRNA that is specific to
prokaryotes and that is the formulated
methionine tRNA so methionine is the
amino acid coded for by the start codon
so in prokaryotes they have their
initiator tRNA is a little bit specific
they have a tRNA that's specific for
formylated methionine so this is their
initiator tRNA so when methionine joins
the tRNA that is specific for the
formulated Metheny it joins to form this
amino acyl tRNA here now that reaction
is catalyzed by a methionine trna
synthetase alright that's the amino acyl
tRNA synthetase and it's specific for
this reaction and of course that
requires an ATP going to an a MP and a
pyrophosphate so the equivalent of two
high-energy phosphate bonds so when we
have this methionine connected to a tRNA
that specific for formulated Metheny but
what is formulated with thiamine well
that's what this next step is for so in
this next step what happens is this
enzyme called Metheny tRNA formulated
methionine formal transferase is
involved
attaching a formal group to this
methionine so this this enzyme attached
is a formal group and a formal group is
is just this here this is a formal group
so that's a one carbon and an oxygen and
hydrogen coming from coming from a
formylated tetrahydrofolate and then the
formal group gets attached so all that's
left that comes out is the
tetrahydrofolate which is involved in
one carbon transfers so what happens is
this methionine becomes formulated so
now what we have here is the long name
is n formyl methionine trna F met
basically it's the amino acyl tRNA for
formula thiamine so you can just write
this as f met tRNA for F met now this
now what we have is a formulated
refining attached to a tRNA specific to
the formulated refining that's exactly
what we wanted here but what's going on
here is that this enzyme is specific to
acting on this particular amino acyl
tRNA I'm a signing attached to a formal
a teen RNA that's specifically
formulated by finding if we took them a
thiamine and a tRNA that specific form
assigning and we use this same enzyme
here so we used Metheny trna synthetase
and again we used the ATP going to a MP
and the pyrophosphate what we get here
is a Metheny attached to tRNA from a
thiamine now this is different because
this is not for a formulated with ine
right this up here was for a formal
finding here we're only just just for a
regular Metheny so if we bring in a
formal a formal group attached to a THF
and you bring this this enzyme here if
this enzyme is here we're actually not
going to have a reaction there will be
no reaction
oops because this enzyme is specific to
acting on this tRNA if this tRNA is not
present it will not work so I just
wanted to go over that idea and talk
about how the initiator tRNA in
prokaryotes has this formulated
methionine
I hope that video was helpful one last
thing I am a tutor if you live in
Southern California feel free to contact
me via email at MU for university at
gmail.com see the description below for
more details thank you for watching